these what are your tips on respecting
your quote documentary subject for lack
of an org their environment especially I
mean you were dealing with people are
women giving birth and husbands
what are some your tips of coming in
respecting that environment and at the
same time getting the footage that you
mean hmm good one a good question we
always you know try to be as unobtrusive
as possible which is obvious everybody
knows that but um we just I mean I feel
like we just tried to kind of stay in
the background a wat and especially in
prenatal visits and stuff but it's very
hard when you have a camera I mean and
somebody's having a prenatal visit or
having a baby I mean you know these
women trusted us because the midwives
trusted us so we have been filming for
quite some time and then we would be
invited into these scenarios that are
quite intimate and that was because the
midwives said that it was okay and and
or the women felt so strongly about
putting out this message about natural
birth in that there's another way or you
know intervention Freiburg I should say
that you know they they really vouch for
us and so that's why we were able to be
in a lot of those situations I think you
know we weren't the type people were
like pressing and pressing and pressing
if somebody didn't want to talk about
something we just kind of let it go and
we try to revisit it at another time um
we we just I think that's not our
personalities are too lightly you know
if somebody's doing something that might
be sort of sensationalistic whatever it
is and might be great on film like if it
didn't feel right we wouldn't
we wouldn't film it or include it and I
think we both just kind of see things
like that we feel like these people are
trusting us and we need to be your spot
it's like yeah and it's and it's a it
sort of depends on how you think about
the art of documentary filmmaking or
what the role of the filmmaker is it's
like if you're telling someone's story
whose story is it is it theirs or is it
yours and you're you're making the film
and it's your film but there has to be
that like that sort of sliver of overlap
where it's not just yours to go and take
so you have to have a kind of respect
you have to have boundaries also you
know and so there's that like there has
to be there have to be clear boundaries
and then there also has to be some flow
of understanding that this is someone
else's story someone else's life this is
someone else's you know image and and
they're trusting you with that and so I
you know I think we asked ourselves like
on a number of occasions you know like
what is the third way if it's not mine
exclusively and it's not theirs
exclusively what is the middle path of
sort of mutual respect and understanding
and and you know so for example i dinnae
you know she signed all of her release
forms she didn't have cut over the film
or you know whatever some filmmakers you
know show the film to them when the film
is over here's the film you know um I
remember talking to the filmmaker RJ
Cutler about that and he said well you
know taking your ear film to the person
who made it and showing it to them as
challenging is that my beer as scary as
that might be is like the price you pay
for that intimate access is like going
and screening the film for them and
looking them in the eyes and I loved
hearing that from him um you know and
that's what we did was animating we flew
her out we took her in the film wasn't
totally done yet so that so that there
was that that there was that space there
where if she said something and it made
sense to us there was space for us to
work with what her feedback was
to be able to take it in not that we
were going to necessarily change it and
it is yeah but to listen and to create
guy's face Krista i think you have you
have to that's the only way to truly
honor like what's what's the truth about
the situation you know it's not mine
it's not ours and it's not hers but it's
somewhere in between and so you know the
only thing she asked us to change was
are the first title card that talked
about the farm the film referred to the
farm as a commune and she said you know
we really never used that word we never
wanted to be called a kommune we always
thought of ourselves as an intentional
community and we were like okay those
are only now yeah we were like okay we
can change that so that would mean that
was a surprise for us and a relief in a
way that we had made a film at she felt
comfortable with and that she felt that
she was represented in a way that she
wanted to be and that also we touched on
things that she felt were very important
and she wanted out there she wanted us
to show she didn't say she wanted us to
show a breech birth but that's something
that she wants to educate people about
because she doesn't understand why it's
not in medical textbooks anymore because
all breech births basically are
c-sections now and she feels like it's
you know this loss of skills and why
wouldn't they teach people how to
doctors how to deliver breech babies so
we had heard her talk about this over
and over we knew that was something that
was really important for her so we
included it you know we in spending all
this time together we knew what she felt
so passionate about and that so we
really touched on all those things I
think and she felt satisfied about by
that but it's you know it's very tricky
it's I think that we had a lot of
respect for the people that we were
and when we love them I mean I really
have loved our experience with them we
just have so much love and appreciation
for the work that they did it would be
very difficult for me and I'm not going
to speak for you but I know you well
enough to say probably for you do to go
and make a film about people that we did
not like to go and spend three or four
years in like darkness I think would be
very difficult or to have the film come
out and have them feel uneasy about it
you know like it's very sweet because
they I mean there might be moments that
they're not thrilled about I haven't
heard about that I don't know but they
really support the film and that only
helps the film that ina may feels good
about the film she comes out with us and
she's you know does q and A's and is a
part of the whole process it's her film
so it is it is interesting because you
it's not like you have to be willing to
do things that that the subject of the
film may not like you know you can't
just make it all rosy rosy all the time
but but you have to balance that with
like what is the what is the reason why
you're why you're doing that you know I
think that like people people can tend
to to make maybe make something
sensational for the fact of the
sensational aspects of things and we
just we felt like we just it wasn't
going to serve ultimately the the
project to take it in that direction I
mean it was it calm you you know like
there was some there was some Sun intent
it was an intentional community you know
there were there were like any number of
avenues that we could have taken the
film down but we also felt like first of
all everybody knows that story of like
you know the 70s and what you know what
what worked and what didn't
and why got why why her ass everybody
with that you know and it would take
away from all the good work that these
women have done for 40 years and why
just to put in something that people
might think was you know Looney from the
70s why would we do that just it would
discredit all this amazing work that
they've done so I mean there there
wasn't really very much but I don't know
there you know we were just like full of
respect for these women and feel very
lucky that they let us into their lives
so I don't know maybe on a different
project it would be very different on
this project it wasn't an issue it was
like wheat there was a mutual respect
and you know people don't know what goes
in to make of into making a film and
that that's so interesting I can't
imagine what it's like to be on the
other side and not know what you know
all the facets of what go into it
because it would be so unknown and it
could create some anxiety of like what
what is a boiler video no they just saw
my closet it's so messy or you know
that's you know but I can imagine it
would be really unsettling and I'll I
don't like to be necessarily film for
that reason because I know when you're
sitting in an edit room that you know
that person better than they all must
know themselves when you're watching
them on film it's bizarre you get to
know them in this such an intimate way
so anyway it's a very good question and
I don't have a perfect answer it's more
just something that I think we tried to
be quiet we tried to listen we tried to
not overstep we tried to let things go
on as they would have had we not been
there inevitably with the camera around
that's
possible no matter if you know but with
ina may a little bit it was ok because
she is quite comfortable with the camera
we also let them in on the process as as
when when it was appropriate you know
here's what we're doing here's what
we're thinking about for distribution
here's like all the stuff so they did
they didn't feel like we were just like
running off you know there were times
were like oh we need to well we're going
to call them up and explain like here
here's where we are in this particular
face this is what's happening this is
what we're you know this is what's
coming up you know we've tried to do
that being in one interview and this
person started to get upset and and
Sarah was interviewing her and I was you
know doing camera which is kind of a
nice little barrier sometimes and and it
was quiet and the woman was starting to
cry and and Sarah just let it sit there
and she was like you know after a couple
minutes like this seems really hard for
you and it was so intense but having the
courage to let the emotions sit there
without jumping on them and saying God
oh I'm sorry I upset you need a tissue
whatever but just like letting them sit
in the room and letting them flow out
and then finally like it felt like an
hour later Sarah's like this seems
really hard for you and she was like
this is really hard for me and then she
started talking you know like it was
like acknowledging where she was and not
saying oh we'll turn the camera for you
okay but just like sitting there and
letting
happen yeah I was very powerful I have a
friend um who who said she counts 2 30
like when wanted when something awkward
or challenging or you've asked it and
and you've asked a question and and
they've said something but you know it's
not right there that she's just like an
inner mind 12 30 is a long time I think
I tried to do like 10 you know but but
that that impulse like fix it make it
all better do away with the awkwardness
like you like that's you're there to
catch real life and real moments and so
like you have to be willing to provoke a
little bit and also hold just hold the
space for what for the real emotion it's
it's a very risky proposition to make a
film about somebody and it's very risky
to be in a film that someone is making
you about you and that you as filmmakers
and as subjects of films you share that
risk whether you they know it or you
know it like I think it's more it's so
important for for especially as
filmmakers to be mindful of the risk
that the people who are in your film are
taking by being in your film and then I
don't know how to how to convey always
to the subjects that you're taking a
risk as well but you are you're taking a
huge financial risk you're taking a huge
personal you know personal creative
psychological risk and and you throw
your life into it and and so I think
it's really helpful to try to have those
conversations where you say like I know
this might feel difficult and then in
fact I think I would the next one if
there ever is a next one I would
probably have even more like
going to to bring to bear on the
situation at the very outset like this
is risky for us as filmmakers here's why
and this is risky for you as a as a
subject and here's why and and but we
can we can agree to move forward and
this is these are the safety things
we're going to have in place I feel like
the filmmakers know a lot more than the
people about that part yet yeah about
they have no idea when they don't know
what what you're risking as a filmmaker
no right and that's what in our
intention was always you know a positive
one yet with ina may that was never you
know we just wanted to tell her story
but still it's like really intimate
moments what about certain points and
you don't really have to give me any
specifics but where you knew that let's
just walk away from this in terms of not
a film but like a certain segment where
you this is just not going to work and I
don't want to press them anymore was it
that Meredith didn t have that the year
mm-hmm just a couple of things so but we
figured out ways to deal with it in the
Edit room but then we didn't include it
so that's another thing is not realizing
all the tools you have at the moment
when you're shooting you're like trying
to get at a certain subject whatever it
is and then realizing maybe later you
could piece it together you know somehow
in the Edit room but yeah we there were
a couple things that we really wanted
one person to talk about and we couldn't
get it and we tried a number of ways and
so we just put up our hands and sort of
moved on and I think that that's I think
that you have to persevere you have to
try more than once but if it's not
happening it's not happening you know
like how what are you supposed to do
didn't Rob anybody
yeah and you want to preserve the
integrity of the film also keep that
trust there I'm sure to because if they
feel you're pushing too much maybe one
yeah and they didn't want to talk about
it and you just let it be yeah count
authorities great rule it's a good role
it's a handy tool to have in your and
your FileMaker toolbox for sure for sure
you